brie Larson one her Oscar for room
wearing Gucci but her favorite red
carpet look was this calvin klein
sparkly stunner i do think that the
Golden Globes was really really
spectacular and special when I put that
dress on the first time I was
overwhelmed and was the first time I've
ever cried over a garment of clothing et
first introduced you to Christina
Ehrlich the woman behind breeze looks
whether it's physically hanging on the
rack or we're looking at images I would
say it's it's born here well now the
hollywood reporter is profiling the top
25 fashionistas who choose the dresses
that stop us in our tracks before we
mess what I had said was I don't wear
pink I don't wear Sparkle I don't wear
sparkles and I don't wear anything
florally dresses yeah saoirse ronan
Oscar nominated for Brooklyn had a lot
of rules before she met Elizabeth
Saltzman and all she had was like pink
glittery sequins and I put them all on
and everything got like me and who
doesn't have goals to look like Beyonce
one of her stylist a ty hunter with the
guy who had that classic moment of
arranging her train at the Met Gala and
if you want to take selfies like BAE
well he has created the new tie light
phone case stars like gaga and Michelle
Williams use it Kerry Washington to
three lights help you create that
perfect Beyonce contour face warm warm
is kind of noticed a lot of people use
this in the club settings at night time
to give you that glowy you can't go
wrong you look sexy and then the next
one is brilliant which is really super
bright I noticed you don't have to use a
filter that much you know so when you
say no filter you can really mean no
filter you know what I actually saw that
light Michelle Williams had it on her
phone at the Super Bowl everyone was so
exciting about it do you bring it back
for me you're supposed to be my best
friend that was my bad that's my bad I
will get you why I promise I will get
you a hobby waiting
you